[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE ELLIOTT:
Hello, and welcome.
I'm Dave Elliott, Global Product
Lead for Storage Products
here at Google.
I'm a former backup admin, and
I've spent most of my career
in storage and backup.
Most recently, I've been helping
shape Google's cloud storage
offering.
RANDY SERAFINI: And I'm Randy
Serafini, Senior Product
Marketing Manager at Veritas.
Veritas is the
market share leader
in backup with more than
34,000 enterprise customers.
We're here today to talk
to you about cloud storage
backup and some of the
key aspects of making
the decisions on what and when
to move to the cloud as a back
up target.
Dave, let's get started.
DAVE ELLIOTT: OK, so today
we'd like to chat about some
of the emerging challenges
that backup faces,
challenges which make cloud
more and more relevant.
Then will provide
a brief overview
of what types of things you
should be thinking about when
using cloud as a backup target.
Next, Randy will provide
an overview of NetBackup
and discuss how it
simplifies the move to cloud.
And then, I'll
touch a little bit
on our object storage service
named Google Cloud Storage.
We'll close with a few
tangible suggestions
on where to go from here.
So I'm sure you've been
thinking about using
the cloud as a backup
target for some time.
The questions are what's
changed and why now?
So there are significant
continued and emerging
challenges that we face.
We all know that data is growing
at a really, really fast rate
for a variety of reasons.
Generally, we're
spiraling towards a future
where the digital world is
overtaking our entire storage
infrastructure, where
creation, modification,
distribution of digital assets
is becoming easier and easier.
But at the same time, budgets
for storing and protecting
that data are not changing
or at least not as quickly
as the data itself is growing.
The classic do more with less
drumbeat in IT continues.
Another growing
challenge for those in IT
is that they're responsible
for data protection
and they need to align those
activities with business
outcomes.
So forward looking CIOs have
been developing strategies
for quite a while
on how to make sure
that they show their
investments are in fact aligned
with the investments of
growth and they're not just
a cost center.
Finally, security
compliance concerns
continue to be a major
part of your job.
Whether it be a high
profile security
breach or new
regulations, the cost
of meeting these challenges is
really becoming significant.
RANDY SERAFINI:
That's right, Dave.
One emerging example
is the recently
passed EU General Data
Protection Regulation or GDPR.
DAVE ELLIOTT: GDPR.
That's got to be a
government thing.
RANDY SERAFINI: Yeah, say
that five times really fast.
This new regulation will go
into effect in Europe in 2018.
It requires a company
to delete data
if it is no longer used for
the purpose it was collected.
And it requires a company
to delete that data
if an individual revokes
the consent for that company
to hold the data.
Regulations like these have
far reaching implications
to the storage data protection
backup and archiving teams.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Got it, got it.
So it's data growth, fixed
budgets, business alignment,
and then the
security compliance,
these are things that are
significant challenges now.
RANDY SERAFINI: That's correct.
DAVE ELLIOTT: In backup.
RANDY SERAFINI: Yep.
DAVE ELLIOTT: OK, so
let's think a little bit
about some of the
challenges then
of existing backup targets.
When you think about cloud,
you think about, well,
what's the alternative?
So most of you probably
use or have used tape
as your primary backup target.
Tape, however, has
many, many limitations
which are significant and
are becoming more and more
problematic in a world where
data security compliance
and availability are critical.
First, let's talk about
the speed of tape.
No matter how
modern the library,
you're still working
from the limitations
of a linear technology.
Plus tape is usually
stored off-site,
and it's, of course,
offline, meaning
it could take hours
or even days for you
to get the tape back on premise.
While nothing's new about
this problem in tape,
it's more significant of
a limitation in a world
where on demand, always
on is status quo.
Second, remember that
tape is a manual process
with physical devices tapes,
autoloaders, libraries,
that are managed by humans.
In economic terms, tape
can be labor intensive,
but in IT terms
it's just a pain.
That brings me to the third
major challenge of tape.
It can be an unreliable process.
It's error prone,
not necessarily
because tape is unreliable,
but because there
are multiple steps, multiple
devices, and multiple people.
And that leads to multiple
potential points of failure.
RANDY SERAFINI: Dave I think you
made a mistake with your slide.
Where's the icon
for error prone?
DAVE ELLIOTT: Well,
I had a great one,
but I accidentally fat
fingered it and deleted it.
You know, I am only human.
RANDY SERAFINI:
Well, now you know
that's why people need backup.
DAVE ELLIOTT: That's right.
You need to have a secondary
copy and not a manual and error
prone one like tape management.
So let's move on to the
other popular target disk.
Disk is ideal for
delivery of hot data
and has a lot of uses in backup
such as for deduplication.
However, a lot of
folks overuse disk.
It's not designed for long
term retention, it's expensive,
and depending on your
architecture and design
can be really, really
difficult to scale.
So now, let's move on to some of
the key considerations of cloud
storage as you think about
using it for cloud backup.
So we'd like to
touch on three areas
technical considerations,
financial considerations,
and operational considerations.
Let's start with
technical considerations.
This is the one that
most people think about.
First, storage has
to be reliable.
You simply can't ever lose data.
This might be represented
as durability, redundancy,
or geographic diversity.
Second, storage
should be available.
This is more and more important.
Can I get my data when
and where I need it?
This might be reflected in
latency, global reach, network
performance, network
performance and stability,
and will likely have some
sort of service level
agreement attached to it.
Third, the data has to
be safe in the cloud.
As you mentioned
earlier, you can't
afford to fail in this front.
Important considerations
is the type and location
of encryption, access
control mechanisms,
and a track record, a track
record of safety and security.
Ask your cloud vendor.
Next, let's look at
financial considerations.
Prices continue
to fall in cloud,
so let's take a look at how the
tape, disk, and cloud generally
compare.
So capital outlay or hardware
purchasing, disk is expensive
and cloud requires
no upfront purchase.
So cloud has an advantage there.
Capacity costs or ongoing
cost are typically
very low for tape, but remember
that's only a part of storage.
For cloud, in
comparison to tape,
you only pay for what you
actually use and you use it
when you actually need it.
While tape has shipping and
logistics for off-site storage.
Networking cost is
higher for cloud
as you import and export data.
Personnel costs are higher
for tape as it requires,
as you mentioned, some
human intervention,
some human activity, and
has higher recovery costs.
So to find out if it makes
economic sense for you,
I recommend putting
together a spreadsheet that
takes into account
the real cost of tape
and the real cost of cloud.
We'll be doing another
in-depth webinar
on the ROI of tape versus cloud,
so keep an eye out for that.
So now, let's take a look
at the third major component
here the operational
considerations of the cloud.
So moving to the cloud you may
have organizational resistance
from vested interest.
It may be somebody's job it
is to manage the backups,
and they don't want to change.
Change is hard.
You may have resistance
from security teams
or from traditional IT
that's not yet sold on cloud.
So generally a best
practice to overcome
that organizational
resistance is get buy in early
and make them a
part of the process.
Engage your vendors engage
us to help you alleviate
some of these concerns.
Second is workflow.
So some of the
organizational resistance
might come from
people's jobs changing.
So how do you best optimize?
Generally speaking, I would say
think about it ahead of time.
Prepare for having those
individuals be reassigned
to value added services
to create better alignment
with the business.
You also are going to have
vested interest in existing
vendors for storage and backup.
And generally speaking,
the best practice
there is simply be
prepared to switch
though that isn't
typically something
that is a major inhibitor.
Finally, integration.
How difficult is it to move
to the crowd, how tightly
integrated is a solution?
Your backup software
should make it
easy to use disk,
tape, or cloud.
Great, so now let's
talk about NetBackup
and how NetBackup
makes it really,
really simple to
move to the cloud
and really if you can start with
just explaining how NetBackup
views the world
and how NetBackup
is a differentiated product.
RANDY SERAFINI: Sure, I'd be
happy to, Dave, thank you.
When we talk about
NetBackup we are
talking about highly scalable
enterprise class data
protection.
For nearly as long
as I can remember,
and I've been doing
this for a while,
the typical enterprise is
a complex, heterogeneous
environment with a wide
range of applications running
in virtual systems,
physical systems,
and are globally
deployed in multiple data
centers with potentially
thousands of remote offices
everywhere.
When you layer
massive data growth
on top of these complex
global deployments
coming from potentially
hundreds of thousands of VMs
as we see in some of our
largest enterprise customers
on the planet, you need to
be able to scale and manage
petabytes.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Or exabytes.
RANDY SERAFINI: Or
exabytes of data
no matter where it is located
without loss in performance.
What enterprise
customers tell us is they
don't want to run multiple
point products for their data
protection.
The reason for this is they
end up with siloed solutions,
what not only adds cost
and are hard to scale
but introduces significant risk.
This additional cost to
train, manage, and orchestrate
multiple products, but because
the data protection is now
fragmented, significant
risk is introduced
through gaps in
their data protection
that might be discovered
only when it's too late.
Imagine the challenges of
trying to orchestrate recovery
from multiple products in the
event of a major disaster.
This is where I'd
like to introduce
the NetBackup platform
and the sheer power
it brings to the enterprise
in what we call a unified data
protection solution.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Unified
data protection?
RANDY SERAFINI: Yes.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Is that
something that people
understand, unified
data protection?
RANDY SERAFINI: That actually
is a very common industry term.
You talk about point
solutions and then
you talk about unified
data protection.
And that's a great
segue, but I'm not
going to tell you exactly what
unified data protection is just
yet.
DAVE ELLIOTT: So when you think
about point solutions you think
about, somebody once said
that data centers are museums
of past IT decisions
where you've got a point
solution maybe to back
up one set of systems
and another point
solution to set up
another type of solution.
RANDY SERAFINI: Typically
it's broken down either by,
typically it's broken
down by workloads.
So you might have one
application backing up
physical workloads, another data
protection solution backing up
virtual environments.
The list can be-- And you
can have different vendors
coming in because
of acquisitions
from companies that are using
different types of solutions.
And it's not uncommon today
for a number of enterprises
to have multiple point solutions
running in their environment.
DAVE ELLIOTT: So unified
data protection then
is something that NetBackup
is well known for.
RANDY SERAFINI: Oh, absolutely.
That is what we do.
DAVE ELLIOTT: In fact, I
understand in the latest
2016 Magic Quadrant report
for data center backup
and recovery, which I understand
Veritas has been in for what?
RANDY SERAFINI:
We've been in them
for 17 years since the
very beginning of the Magic
Quadrant.
And we are actually still the
number one market share leader
in backup and recovery.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Huh.
RANDY SERAFINI: And what they
had to say about NetBackup
is that NetBackup is the most
evaluated enterprise backup
solution and the most deployed
solution for organizations
with 5,000 or more employees.
DAVE ELLIOTT: 5000
or more employees.
RANDY SERAFINI: Yes.
DAVE ELLIOTT: A very,
very large organization.
RANDY SERAFINI:
That's exactly right.
And the reason for
this is simple.
NetBackup has perhaps
the broadest support
for heterogeneous environments
across virtual, physical,
and cloud.
DAVE ELLIOTT: And cloud.
RANDY SERAFINI: And
allows the enterprise
to manage data protection
as a holistic solution
all from a single
console or by workload.
And because
NetBackup is designed
as a ground up unified data
protection platform, which
includes both software
and a family of tightly
integrated appliances,
NetBackup has the ability
to manage data protection
for the globally deployed
enterprise while maintaining
performance at petabyte.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Or exabyte.
RANDY SERAFINI: Scale, correct.
And providing the holistic
global view of all enterprise
data without the added cost
and risk of point solutions.
The biggest challenges
enterprise customers
tell us and we talk
to a lot of them
is the need to
reduce complexity,
because with complexity
comes cost and risk.
They need to be able to not
only maintain performance
in the face of
massive data growth,
they need to manage and reduce
the cost of this data growth.
The next hot topic
facing the CIO
is how can they
become more agile,
be more efficient
and streamlined
in their operations, eliminate
bottlenecks, and respond better
to new business challenges
and opportunities?
DAVE ELLIOTT: So
simplicity and agility
these are important
differentiators for NetBackup?
RANDY SERAFINI: Absolutely.
DAVE ELLIOTT: OK, great.
So what is another
important differentiator?
RANDY SERAFINI:
Well, the one thing
that you missed was scalability.
DAVE ELLIOTT: OK.
RANDY SERAFINI: So you get
simplicity, scalability,
and agility.
DAVE ELLIOTT: OK, great.
RANDY SERAFINI: OK?
And finally, is visibility.
What they want is
they want to be
able to see all of their
data no matter where it is
and be able to better
leverage that data
or eliminate data that
no longer is of value.
NetBackup 7.7 brings
to the enterprise
what we call a converged
data protection platform.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Converged
Hold on, Randy.
That sounds like some
good marketing fluff.
What does that really mean?
RANDY SERAFINI: Well, when
you think about it today,
we talk about hypervisor
converged platforms,
we talk about
infrastructure converged
platforms, what
that really means
is a tight integration
between software and hardware.
DAVE ELLIOTT: OK.
RANDY SERAFINI:
So what we have is
a unique combination
of NetBackup software
and our integrated family
of NetBackup appliances
that not only simplify the
deployment of NetBackup
but provide massive
enterprise class performance
and scale across workloads
in the enterprise.
Customers that have moved
and consolidated workloads
to the NetBackup
converged platform
have discovered the
ease and simplicity
of managing a unified
data protection platform
across their deployment.
And with the many
performance features
and intelligent policies
to automate and accelerate
backup and recovery,
they have experienced
significant improvements
in both backup performance
and backup success rates as
well as faster recoveries,
not to mention, with
this integrated end
to end deduplication significant
reduction in storage footprint
and costs.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Now I know
what a converged platform is.
Great.
RANDY SERAFINI: That's correct.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Thanks.
RANDY SERAFINI: It
is fully integrated.
What is important
to keep in mind
is that for those
companies that leverage
a single unified data
protection solution that
protects all workloads
and data they
are in a unique position
with the right information
management tools to
get visibility into all
their globally deployed data.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Back
to visibility, right?
RANDY SERAFINI:
Back to visibility.
DAVE ELLIOTT: One of
the key differentiators.
RANDY SERAFINI: One of
our key differentiators.
Whether that data is on
prem, whether it's remote,
or in the cloud, in the cloud.
DAVE ELLIOTT: In the cloud.
Hopefully Google's cloud.
RANDY SERAFINI: You can get
actionable intelligence.
A perfect example of
this right kind of tool
is our exciting new Veritas
Information Map solution,
that in a matter of minutes
can import NetBackup's catalog
and index data and present a
global view of that data, where
it's located, how much is
there, and with the ability
to double click and understand
what kind of data it is.
And more importantly does that
data represent unlocked value
or can that cost be eliminated?
OK, now that you have
a pretty good idea why
so many enterprise
customers love NetBackup,
let's talk about cloud.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Cloud, love it.
Lets talk about cloud.
RANDY SERAFINI: Well, I thought
you might like to do that.
DAVE ELLIOTT: OK.
RANDY SERAFINI: So we know
today the world has an expanding
lineup of cloud vendors with
more coming online every day
in just about any
flavor you can imagine.
This is the good news
and the bad news.
The good news is that
you have more choice,
and we all love more choice.
The bad news is you
have more choice.
DAVE ELLIOTT: You can
just pick Google Cloud.
RANDY SERAFINI: You could just
do that make it simple, right?
DAVE ELLIOTT: Yeah.
RANDY SERAFINI: Well, where
NetBackup can play a key role
with helping to
simplify your decision
is its natural ability to extend
data protection and management
to the cloud as if it
was just another globally
deployed enterprise data
center or target storage device
only now these resources
are in the cloud.
When you look at the real
bench strength of NetBackup,
it has the ability to scale
and protect these workloads
no matter where they reside
and can easily move and keep
track of this data whether
it's on disk, tape, appliance,
or in the cloud or
even multiple clouds.
DAVE ELLIOTT: So it's
scale and not just
scale in terms of more servers
but more servers across more
locations and more types.
RANDY SERAFINI: No
matter where it resides.
DAVE ELLIOTT: OK, great.
RANDY SERAFINI:
With NetBackup we
have a growing list of
integrated cloud connectors
and data reduction technologies.
And with a single click
from the NetBackup console,
you can start target backups
to your cloud vendor of choice.
In addition to connecting
to your favorite cloud
provider of choice via NetBackup
integrated cloud connectors,
you can leverage a wide range of
cloud gateways such as NetApp's
AltaVault or store
reduce with deduplication
that can further reduce the cost
of replacing tape to the cloud.
Our support for Google
Nearline is robust.
It enables to use cloud storage
as an alternative to tape
when choosing a long term
storage of backup data.
It also allows backup
of large volumes
of data at a very low cost
and that can get access
to it at any time.
DAVE ELLIOTT: This is great.
I don't need to
talk about Nearline.
You're talking about some
of the great benefits.
RANDY SERAFINI: No,
it's all pretty simple.
Once you use NetBackup and
target Google, you're all set,
you're ready to go.
We can manage it for you
and take care of it for you.
DAVE ELLIOTT: You've got
your Nearline, which I'll
talk about in just a minute.
Let's talk about
integration through OST.
RANDY SERAFINI: Well, OST is one
of our very special features.
It allows storage vendors
to actually integrate
tightly with NetBackup
and allows NetBackup
to see all that data where it's
located within that storage
vendor.
And we do the same thing
with all of our connectors
into the cloud.
So by leveraging this
unique OST layer,
NetBackup can continue
to monitor and backup
all backup information
regardless of location,
whether it's on disk,
on tape, or cloud.
So you have NetBackup lifecycle
management capabilities,
which also manages the when
and how information is moved.
This is critical, whether
you move from online disk
or to Google Cloud
Storage Nearline.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Great.
RANDY SERAFINI: Recent
enhancements in NetBackup 7.7
with multiscreen technology,
significantly improves
backup and recovery
performance by up to 30 times
for compatible cloud storage.
And a truly unique enterprise
feature in NetBackup
is its Audio Image Replication
or NetBackup backup AIR.
Our customers love this feature.
This technology allows companies
to automate and accelerate
disaster recovery
through configurable,
WAN optimized application of
deduplicated backup images
and catalog data to
remote locations.
Many NetBackup
customers are looking
to simplify their
disaster recovery
by leveraging cloud platforms
as the remote disaster recovery
site with our AIR technology.
DAVE ELLIOTT: So
simplification, we're
hearing again
hearing agility,
scale, and visibility.
RANDY SERAFINI: And visibility.
DAVE ELLIOTT: OK.
RANDY SERAFINI: Those are the
real strengths of NetBackup.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Great.
RANDY SERAFINI:
Most importantly,
support for Google Nearline
is single click simple.
Bring up the cloud
storage UI in NetBackup,
click on Google Nearline, and
enter the Google credentials
and you are now ready
to back up to the cloud.
It's that simple.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Fantastic.
RANDY SERAFINI: Now, I'd
like to hand it back to Dave
to discuss how Google
Cloud Storage is
differentiated and is a great
fit as a backup storage target.
Dave, it's all yours.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Thanks.
So a quick introduction
to Google Cloud Storage.
It's our cloud object store,
which is a great place
to store backups.
Google Cloud Storage allows
you to store access and manage
your unstructured data on
Google's infrastructure.
So it's the same
storage that Google
uses for images in
Google Photos, Gmail
attachments, Google Docs.
Cloud objects store
offers unlimited scale,
global availability,
it's highly durable,
and it has very, very low cost.
So what are some of the
Google Cloud Storage
key differentiators?
First, our massive
scalability, which means you'll
never have to be concerned with
running out of storage again.
Second, our global network,
which we built and own,
means better latency and more
reliable network performance.
Third, our price leadership.
This means you know you'll
be getting the best value.
We compare favorably not only to
on prem storage disk and tape,
but also to other
cloud providers.
On average we're 13%
to 20% less expensive.
Fourth, what I'll
call interesting value
added services.
These are cloud services that
you can apply to your data
when it's in our cloud.
Things like data analytics and
machine learning for instance.
Fifth, all of Google's
cloud storage offerings
use a consistent single API.
No need to write API
for standard storage
and another for archive.
And then finally,
the tight integration
with backup solutions such
as NetBackup and Backup Exec,
means that it's very
simple to get started.
So now, I want to briefly
introduce Google Cloud
Storage's services.
So we have three
specific services.
The first is standard
storage, which
is highly performant
and highly available
and is ideally suited
for hot applications.
Durable, reduced availability
is exactly what its name says,
it provides slightly
lower availability
with the same durability
and performance
and it costs a little bit less.
Nearline, though, is
ideally designed for backup.
Nearline is what NetBackup has
tightly integrated into its UI.
It's low cost, only a
penny a gig per month.
But you do pay for
reads, so it's ideally
designed for those
use cases where
you don't read the data
frequently such as backup.
It's highly durable 11.9,
durability built in.
And again, it's integrated
with NetBackup and Backup Exec.
So now, let's close with
a few ideas on where
you can go from here.
What and when do you
move data to the cloud?
Data moving to the cloud, any
data that's older than 30 days
I think 90% of backup
restores are from data
that's less than 30 days.
So after 30 days you
can move it to a cloud.
RANDY SERAFINI: That's correct.
But there's another
interesting statistic, Dave.
And that is research
has shown that
after 90 days, 97% of the data--
DAVE ELLIOTT: 97%, OK.
RANDY SERAFINI: 97%
is no longer accessed.
So think about that.
You have all this data
sitting on expensive disk
after 90 days just
sitting there.
DAVE ELLIOTT: So move it.
RANDY SERAFINI: What's a
good thing to do with it?
DAVE ELLIOTT: Move it to the
cloud as quickly as you can
after 30 days or 60 days.
So data and remote office and
branches, the typical robo use
case is a great place
for you, the type
of data to move to the
cloud because you already
have to traverse the network.
A secondary copy of
backup data so disk
to disk to cloud as
you might call it
is a great type
of data that gets
moved, data that's generally
on prem that has filled up
your data center, filled
up your disk array,
filled up your local
cache, and then
data that supporting
a BCDR plan.
So that's a type
of data typically,
do you agree with that?
RANDY SERAFINI: I do, yes.
DAVE ELLIOTT: And then
the catalyst events,
the things that drive people
to make decisions to consider
cloud, perhaps the reason
people are watching this webinar
right now.
First, tape equipment
is coming off lease
or it is simply
reaching obsolescence.
So you need to
replace your tape.
Second, launching, perhaps,
a cloud first initiative
internally, perhaps
a server or desktop
virtualization project or
wholesale infrastructure
upgrades.
It could be that
there's new people
and new people are willing to
try and do things differently.
Or it could be some sort
of consolidation issue
where they're
looking to take some
of those vast pools
of tape and disk
that are all over
their infrastructure
and consolidate them and
create some efficiencies.
So just a few ideas on,
hopefully some tangible ideas,
on what type of
data typically gets
moved to the cloud and
then some catalyst events.
So very quickly a very
high level architecture,
a very simple
architecture, that might
look like either using
direct backup from NetBackup
or any backup vendor
directly to the cloud
or by leveraging a
gateway using NetBackup
through a gateway to GCS.
And then finally, I'd
like to summarize and do
a simple recap.
Now, there are some emerging
challenges in backup.
The backup
environment's changing
with more and more data,
more and more regulations,
and then a desire or
really requirement
to better support the
business to better
align with the business.
Tape and disk limitations
are even more significant
in this era, right,
with high data growth,
constrained budgets,
and an on demand world.
And when thinking about
storage for backup
there are technical, financial,
and operational considerations
that we barely touched on.
Hopefully, we gave you
a construct for you
to think about and
for you to go and have
a conversation with your team
as to whether cloud makes sense.
We finished with an
introduction to NetBackup
and how NetBackup is
designed for the entire
for the whole global enterprise.
And we introduced Google
Cloud Storage Nearline
as a highly durable,
globally available, low cost,
limitless data storage pool
that's tightly integrated
with NetBackup.
So finally, a few suggestions
on where to go from here.
I try to make it as
tangible as possible.
First, experiment.
It's the cloud, right, it's
designed to experiment,
it's designed to play with.
RANDY SERAFINI:
And to reiterate,
Dave, its single click simple.
Because it's so tightly
integrated in NetBackup,
all you've got to
do is pull the UI,
pull up the storage cloud
component of NetBackup,
and click on Google Nearline,
put the credentials in,
and you now are ready to back
up to Google Cloud Service.
DAVE ELLIOTT: So
experiment, try it.
If you're a NetBackup
user today, it's simple.
Second thing is get
buy-in from stakeholders
for some of those stakeholders
that were concerned
with the change
in their workday,
the change in the
process, changing vendors,
get buy-in from them early.
Run the numbers.
Go ahead and create
that spreadsheet
and go and get the
real numbers so you
can compare the cost to tape
versus crowd versus disk.
Don't reindex your tapes and
upload them, just cut over.
Just leave the old ones and let
them age off, let them expire.
And then finally, related to
the experimentation, leverage
the promotion.
We've got a $300 new
customer promotion
running right now where
you can go and sign up
in a few simple clicks.
It's literally I
think four minutes.
And you can leverage that
promotion with your NetBackup
instance today and get started
and start experimenting.
A couple of areas for you
to get more information,
you can read the new ESG
White Paper on data protection
to the cloud.
And you can also,
of course, read
the technical brief that is
NetBackup and Google Cloud
Storage.
So thank you for your time,
and please look forward
to our other webinars.
RANDY SERAFINI: Dave,
thank you for inviting
us to share NetBackup
with you and with all
of our customers and
potential customers out there.
We're excited about
the opportunity
to be able to use NetBackup
to leverage the cloud.
That's where people
are going and that's
where the enterprise is going.
And we want to be able
to help enable that.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Fantastic.
RANDY SERAFINI:
Thank you so much.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]